The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Welcome back, everyone,
and me too.
I just came back from Boulder
where I gave eight talks.
I was on seven panels and
gave one separate
talk, most on education.
And one of the talks was
on teaching how to
think or what to think.
So there were three panelists,
one professor from Berkeley in
the astronomy department, who
is also a renowned teacher,
and then an investigative
journalist, and then I spoke.
And we all said something
for about 10 minutes.
I talked about the history
of education and why it's
difficult to change educational
institutions and
educational practices and what
the original purposes of the
schools were, so some of this
material that I'll talk about
in the second to last lecture
on political barriers to
educational change.
And I then also, before this
whole session, I described to
the reporter for the Daily
Camera, which is the paper in
Boulder, a bit about what
I was going to say.
And I talked about some of the
material I've told you already
about multiplication table.
So if you remember, the
multiplication table, when
people get brain damage in the
arithmetic area, they can't do
addition anymore, but they
can still do the
multiplication table.
And when people get brain damage
in the language area,
they can still do addition,
but they can't do
multiplication anymore.
And that's because
multiplication, generally, is
learned as--
So when you see it, you think
of symbols and math, but
actually the way most people
learn it is 6 times 9 is 54.
Then you have to memorize
yet another fact.
9 times 6 is 54.
Oh.
And then you have to learn yet
a new fact, that these two
facts are related, when,
actually, if you understood
the meaning, there would
be just one fact.
So now you have to memorize all
these linguistic sentences.
And no surprise, when you get
damage in the linguistic area,
that kind of multiplication
table goes away.
So I said to the reporter, yeah,
what we really need to
do is teach multiplication and
math in a whole different way.
So the reporter, she understood
everything and
said, oh, that's really
interesting.
I'm actually studying education
myself, and I have children.
And I'll try to apply that with
my children and in the
teaching that I do.
I said, oh, great.
So then, I gave my talk, and
then the moderator asked
everybody, well, does anyone
on the panel want to say
anything to anybody else?
And so Alex Filippenko from
Berkeley, he stood up and he
said, well, I agreed with
everything that Sanjoy said,
except he was quoted in the
paper this morning as saying
we shouldn't teach the
multiplication table.
So that whole discussion, which
seemed to be completely
understood, just got condensed
into one sentence.
So now I didn't actually have to
say very much in response,
because the second panelist,
as I mentioned, was an
investigative journalist.
And what she was talking about
is how you have to be very
skeptical of what's
in the media.
So all I had to do was look
at her for a bit, and then
everybody started laughing
because the point was clear.
But then I explained to
everybody else what I'd
explain to the reporter.
That's by way of saying that
education is a complicated
subject, but the audience
understands a lot more than
the media does, which is one of
the barriers to political
change is that there's people
who understand lots of
individual points, but how
do you assemble it into a
coherent plan for change?
Well, you need forums
for discussion.
And if the reports in the media
are, oh, don't teach the
multiplication table, or do
teach it but do it with lots
of drill, well, it's hard to get
in a discussion of, well,
actually you'd like to teach it
in a different way, where
instead of memorizing this you
say, well, 6 times 9 is like 6
times 10, which is 60,
minus 6, which is 54.
So there's no space for putting
things like that into
public discussion.
And one of the purposes
of classes like
this is to do that.
OK.
Today, we're going to talk about
lecture planning and
performing.
What we've done so far is the
flow of the ideas in this
class has gone as follows.
So this is a logical flow.
We did it slightly out of
order, because it's the
preparation flow, slightly
different
than the logical flow.
You work out your course
goals, or even
your curriculum goals.
And then you decide, how are
you going to tell whether
you've reached those goals?
Let me just write the goal
a little clearer.
And with problems, tests,
that's the way you
operationalize your goals.
And then given that you have
those kind of problems, well,
now you have a pretty concrete
idea of what it is you're
trying for, because you have
concrete examples of it.
Well, lectures, recitations,
so I'll put et cetera here.
What do you do with
your contact time?
This is the overall structure.
This is at the level where
it makes concrete sense.
And this is, what do you do when
the rubber hits the road,
what do you do in lecture?
Last time, what we
did is we talked
about interactive teaching.
And there was, basically,
several time scales over which
you can make the class
interactive.
The longest time scale was the
wood blocked example, and I'll
answer a question about
that in just a moment.
So now, continuing the theme of
where the rubber hits the
road, today--
Now that you have some
techniques, how do you
assemble it into a lecture?
And I use both words advisedly
and deliberately.
So plan, it's essential
to plan.
And performance is essential.
People forget that.
They forget that lecturing and
teaching is a public act, and
when they forget that, the
lectures are flat.
We're going to talk about the
techniques for doing that,
starting with the Walter
Lewin lecture that
you watched for today.
Because he actually has many,
many examples, I think mostly
good, of performance, and
some that I think he
could improve on.
And we'll discuss that and work
out and induce general
principles that you can use.
OK.
Those are the questions
from last time.
There was a slight review of
interactive teaching as well
and things like this.
Now the question is, what
do you do in lecture?
How do you plan, and
how do you perform?
And a good way to start
discussing that was actually
to look at a master of the
art and see what they do.
Now no master is perfect.
But I think Walter Lewin did
so many things well it's
really worth understanding what
he did and looking at it.
So what did you notice from
your homework problem?
Basically, what did you
notice that he did?
And I have a bunch of
things as well.
And we'll just write
them down.
Because what we'll
do, as before--
we've done this several times
now-- by looking at examples,
we can induce general
principles.
Actually, I'll leave
this here, and
I'll erase these guys.
While I'm erasing, just pull
out your homework and the
things you've noted down.
And actually, take a minute
and check in with your
neighbor and see if your
lists overlap.
And sort of vet your lists
with each other.
And if you didn't think about
anything that could be
improved, see if you can
remember anything that you
would have done differently.
So let's share all the points.
So I can see that you've come up
with a lot of examples, and
I actually had a bunch
too, because
it's such a rich lecture.
So let's see what things that
were done and what was either
that you would keep or
you would change.
And I'll put them in one or the
other side, according to
how you categorize them.
Any one example?
Yeah, Wendy.
AUDIENCE: He awards students
when something might not be
intuitive for them
or something.
So when he was doing analysis
of error under the square
root, and he was saying, OK,
this might not be something
you would know right now.
I might not hold you
responsible, but it's
interesting [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So he tell students,
look, this is
harder or not intuitive.
He gives them a gauge and tells
them, look, you're don't
have to worry about it before
he says something.
He gives the difficulty
of something.
OK.
Why is that helpful?
What does that do
for students?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It sort of removes the
tension of thinking, oh,
man, I don't know this while
they're trying to pay
attention to the other
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right.
So it differentiates
the lecture.
So I'll put in other
color the reasons.
Yeah, so it gives some kind of
differentiation to the lecture.
It gives a structure to it.
It gives you a way of evaluating
so you know what
are you supposed to be
doing here and trying
to learn from it.
You don't all of a sudden
trigger your reflex fear.
So it minimizes fear.
And it gives a clear
expectation.
So in the particular lecture, he
didn't say anything was you
absolutely have to know this.
So there wasn't a
flip example.
But if it had been a flip
example, it would have the
same benefit.
If he said, oh, this is
really fundamental.
You really, really, really,
really need to know this,
well, that also punctuate
the lecture.
So it minimize fear and
sets expectations.
To expand on this point, which
is really fundamental, think
about the difference between
the way a novice perceives
something and the way an expert
perceives something.
If you want to know how a novice
perceives something,
try to remember from the days
when you were not a chess
Grandmaster.
That shouldn't be too hard
for most of us, certainly
not hard for me.
You look at a chessboard,
all the moves
look kind of similar.
Oh, I could move that pawn.
You think about that
for a bit.
You analyze some moves.
He takes, I take, he
takes, I take.
Hmm, OK, let me think about--
I could move the rook.
I could castle.
He takes, I take, or I'll
move the bishop.
And you sort of say, OK,
I'll move the bishop.
That's how the novice or medium
chess player thinks,
speaking from personal
experience.
The way the master or the
Grandmaster looks at the
chessboard, the chessboard
has meaning.
All the different pieces
of it are kind of
talking to each other.
Hmm, that pawn structures
is really full of holes.
You really want to do something
about that.
So the undifferentiated mass of
pieces that the notice sees
is completely different from
what the expert sees, which is
why the expert can remember
the chessboard
and the novice can't.
I noticed this exact
same thing happened
in my freshman year.
I learned to play bridge I'd
never played bridge before,
and all my friends, who I don't
know if they did me a
favor or not, taught me to play
bridge so I could play
bridge with them.
When I first was playing with
them, at the end of the hand,
everyone does the post mortem.
You have four people, you play
all the tricks, and everyone
talks about what happened
and it didn't happen.
And they would say, Oh,
yeah, why didn't you
play the queen then?
I was like queen of what?
What queen?
Did I have a queen?
I didn't even remember
the cards I had.
how many cards
I had of each thing.
I just sort of remembered
the last card, maybe.
Or more like, oh, phew,
the hand's over.
OK.
I can't make anymore mistakes.
That's how I would see
it compared to how
they would see it.
And I was like, how could they
ever even remember who had the
queen of what?
And by the end of, I don't know,
six months, I would say,
uh, why didn't you play
the five then?
Because all of a sudden,
now I was doing
exactly the same thing.
The hands had meaning.
The cards had meaning.
So by doing this, by giving
clues to the difficulty or
ease of things, you're actually
giving meaning.
You're transferring some of that
knowledge that you have
as the expert to the student,
who otherwise wouldn't know.
There was another example of
that in the lecture where he
said, this is the
most important
equation in all of physics.
He wrote that, and he boxed
it, and he said, that's
probably the most important
equation in all of physics.
So again, he's giving something
that the expert knows.
Because the expert knows, oh,
yeah, when you see this,
you're home free, and you know
you can model so many physical
systems with this.
Let's tell the students how
important it is so they have
some way of thinking about it.
OK So that's really
fundamental.
Others?
Other points?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: He uses big ideas
and terms for them, like
uncertainty and restoring
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So he uses clear terms for big
ideas, and he uses the same
term each time.
He's careful to do that,
so you don't
wonder why it changed.
How does that help students,
to give things names and
repeatable names?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Gives them fewer
facts to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It gives a structure
to everything.
It's gone now.
But it gives a structure,
repeatable abstractions that
you can reuse over
and over again.
Structures.
In fact, it's another
example of this.
It structures the knowledge.
So it's structured
in his mind.
He's the expert.
He has a really good, sound
flexible structure.
And part of the job of really
good teaching is to help the
students build that structure.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When he's
characterizing visions, he
really emphasizes building
intuition for why the vision
is the way it is and why
it's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So he emphasizes the why
of the equation.
So why is it plausible that
it, for example, has--
Can you give an example
of that?
AUDIENCE: He talked a bit
about why [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
There was an example where the
frequency was derived, so
emphasizes the physical
meaning and
interpretations also.
And interpretation.
So the example he gave, which I
think is a good one, is in a
pendulum, why is the period
independent of the mass?
For a pendulum--
OK.
And the argument for that was,
oh, well, if you double the
mass, you double the force, but
you double the mass, so
you haven't changed
the acceleration.
So everything stays the same.
And he contrasted that.
He didn't just do this one.
He contrasted that with what
happens in a spring.
OK.
So how does this help
the students?
What's the benefit?
AUDIENCE: I think it helps them
because it makes them
feel like they could potentially
derive it
themselves and then afterwards
check their answer.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
He's modeling, actually,
what you would do.
You, yourself, as a physicist,
and hopefully as a student,
you want to be able to
check your answer by
making sense of it.
It promotes sense-making
is a shorthand for it.
Let me just push the
other board up.
AUDIENCE: Well, and it's
also [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: --which is
probably the most
difficult thing to teach.
I thought that was the best
part of the lecture.
One thing is to give a list of
facts so you learn and then
you can use.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: That seems to be the
closest to teaching how to
think, which is the most
difficult thing
you can ever teach.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It teaches how to think,
because it's a
transferable skill.
You may never have to analyze a
pendulum again as a student
outside of the class.
But whatever formula you get,
you can use that same method
to say, does the formula
make sense?
So that's teaching a
way of thinking.
It's a transferable skill.
Yeah, Adrian.
AUDIENCE: He's very, very
explicit about his notation.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Explicit about notation.
Can you give an example?
AUDIENCE: Well, even
when [INAUDIBLE]
method of a string,
he says, this is
the method of a string.
And he'll label an equation with
the whole, writes it out.
In [INAUDIBLE] terms.
PROFESSOR: Right.
He'll write everything out.
So he's very explicit
about notation.
How does that help
the students?
What does that do for them?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It makes it
clearer and it makes
mistakes hard to make.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It makes it hard to
make mistakes.
Again, so this is hard
to make mistakes.
Harder--
OK.
And what makes it harder, and
why is this so important?
Because, as Adrian said, yeah,
it may be intuitively obvious
to the expert physicist that,
of course, L is the length.
That's why you chose L, because
length begins with L.
But for the student,
everything is new.
The chess example, the knocking
down the chessboard
problem and seeing how well
you can reconstruct it,
explains so much.
The novice, they can't
reconstruct the chessboard.
That's because each piece
on the chessboard is not
intuitively obvious.
Whereas, for the chess master,
it's so easy to reconstruct
the board, because, to them,
it is intuitively obvious
that, of course, you
have three pawns in
front of your king.
Unless you have some really
crazy opening, of course
you've castled your kind and you
have three pawns sitting
in front of it protecting it.
And it's just obvious from the
configuration of the pawns
that, of course, with that pawn
configuration you did
this opening.
And of course, the king is
defended in this way.
So what's obvious to the expert
is completely obscure
to the non-expert.
You want them to not have to
worry and fill up their
short-term memory slots with
things that really are
obvious, so you put that
right on the diagram.
He wrote M, I think, and then
there was an L there.
So right away, you just
look at the diagram.
You know what L is.
OK.
Other things that were done?
There are so many.
AUDIENCE: He asked the students
to help [INAUDIBLE]
passively but actively.
PROFESSOR: OK.
He asked for help.
That increased participation.
How did he ask for help?
What were some examples
of that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the gun spray toward
the [INAUDIBLE]
of the harmonic motion, he
asked a student for help
holding the end of the paper.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And then, when
he drew the big
pendulum where he--
PROFESSOR: Oh, the
final pendulum.
Right.
Several times, actually--
let's see.
I think I have it here--
Lewin says, I want to hear
you loud, because
he didn't hear them.
He wanted people to really
participate, and then they
really started counting.
So they were really involved in
what's going to happen by
the end of 10 swings.
It involved them, so it's a form
of interactive teaching.
He's getting people
more involved.
Yes, Adrian.
AUDIENCE: On the other hand, I
thought he pretty much never
asked questions.
PROFESSOR: OK.
He didn't ask them questions.
Right.
Yeah, it's good that he asked
for help, and that is one way
of involving them.
So it made them interested, but
it didn't necessarily--
It increased their motivation
to learn about the subject,
but it didn't necessarily
actually help them learn right
then about something.
So he would change.
OK.
Can anyone else think the spots
where he could have
asked questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think there were
natural pauses, natural breaks
[INAUDIBLE].
For instance, when the air
tracks through the pendulum,
he didn't stop there.
He never stopped to let students
think about what they
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
He didn't pause at the
natural break points.
AUDIENCE: He didn't pause
at the natural--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
One example that I remember of
that, because I was also
watching for that, was he wanted
to show Hooke's law and
he plotted out--
I'll draw an example here.
He plotted force verses
extension for a bunch of
extensions.
And forces was the weight
of those springs.
And he got a bunch of points
here, and he drew this.
Then he pulled one of the
springs, and he stretched the
hell out of it.
And then he let go of it, and it
came back much longer than
it started.
And then he drew what happened
on the graph.
So one thing he could have done,
rather than drawing it
straight, is the following.
You say, OK, how do we describe
what happened to that
spring as I stretched it?
Was it this curve, that
curve, or that curve?
A, B, C. You don't have to
spend long on it, just 10
seconds, or even 30 seconds.
But instead, he just told
them which it was.
So actually, which was
it, A, B, or C.
AUDIENCE: C.
PROFESSOR: C. Right.
It was C. And just the act of
thinking about that forces you
to connect the physics and the
mathematics once again, even
this small amount.
Yes, Lat.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
same apply to you?
I've never thought about
asking a question.
Maybe you answered
it immediately.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
He didn't pause at natural
break points, and he
didn't pause at--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
smaller time scale?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Not the smaller time scale.
Right.
No five-second pause.
So the questions are
almost rhetorical.
I would say it's one of the
dangers of being such a good
performer, which he is.
He's fantastic, I think.
And one of the things he does so
well in his performance is
connecting--
which you mentioned
over here--
the physics and the mathematics,
explaining the
physical meaning and
interpretation, that top item.
He does that so well.
But one of the dangers of being
such a good performer is
that you just steamroller over
the students, and you become,
in some ways, more important
than the students.
Yeah.
You'd be able to do less in
lecture, but the five-second
pause is really important to
have everyone tracking and
following with you.
Other items?
Let's see.
Someone I haven't--
Yeah, Tsu.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes, when
he says, this is totally
non-intuitive, he kind of
just accepted that.
And I think it would have been
nice if he had given a reason
for why this had to be, instead
of just saying--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
When he said things were
non-intuitive, he sometimes
didn't explain why it
was non-intuitive.
So the one I'm thinking of is
he said, no matter what the
amplitude is, the period
is the same.
And he said it isn't
intuitive.
So that was good, in that
he did tell people--
Where was that?
Yeah, it's here.
He gives a difficulty.
He says, for example, this
isn't intuitive.
You should be surprised that the
period is independent of
the amplitude.
But he doesn't give them
another way of seeing
why it should be.
They do the derivation, and
you find that it is
independent of the amplitude.
But why?
And you can explain
that sort of
intuitively just by saying--
I'll give you a quick
explanation of that.
So it is, actually,
an amazing fact.
I'll give you a quick
explanation of the unintuitive
fact that the period is
independent of the amplitude.
OK?
This is a scaling argument.
E, G. OK.
Let's estimate how long it
takes a mass to move a
distance, A. Well, it has some
acceleration, a, small a.
This is the amplitude, and
that's the period.
So the mass has some
acceleration, little a.
And in some time, t, the period,
or some fraction of
the period, let's say a quarter
of the period, it goes
this distance, give or take
factors of 2 and whatnot.
So this is roughly
the amplitude.
Now we want to figure out,
what is this A here?
Well, A is the force
over the mass.
And the typical force, that's
coming from the spring.
So it's a spring constant
times the extension.
The typical extension
is the amplitude.
OK?
k times A is your force, divided
by m, so we'll put
that in there.
OK.
Oh, look at that.
Hmm.
And in fact, there you have
t is proportional to
square root of m/k.
So you've got not only that
it's independent of the
amplitude, but you've
got the whole story,
except for the 2 pi.
So intuitively, what it's saying
is that, yeah, if you
move yourself farther out,
you have father to go.
But you're pulled harder
by just enough to make
the time the same.
And so not only is
it an intuitive
argument, it's very plausible.
And Galileo extended it to the
pendulum, and he thought he
found a proof to show that the
pendulum actually has a period
independent of amplitude.
In the pendulum, the amplitude
is related to the restoring
force, so he thought the period
of the pendulum was
independent of amplitude, not
just for a regular spring.
And that proof turned out to
have a slight error in it.
But as Walter Lewin pointed out,
that's only true at large
angles, and at small angles, you
can't tell the difference.
So you can actually explain
these non-intuitive pieces in
short ways that don't require
doing a full calculation.
And that is important
to do, I think.
OK.
So why don't we take
a 10-minute
break, and then we'll--
Oh, do you have a
quick comment?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: One other thing that I
thought he should have done.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Which is
actually motivate
why this is so important.
He mentioned [INAUDIBLE], as you
said, that it's the most
important thing in physics.
But actually, I thought it would
have been nice to give
some real examples of
how [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
Answer the "Who cares?"
question.
Right.
And that's a good point.
I teach physics myself, so
actually that one slipped me.
Because this is, again,
the expert blind spot.
So he put that equation there,
and I was so glad he said,
most important equation
in physics.
And to myself, I thought,
yeah, right on.
You use it in electromagnetism.
The whole theory of quantum
electrodynamics depends on it.
You use it in modeling
materials.
It's everywhere.
So all those thoughts went
through my mind right away.
And I thought, wow, that's
equivalent to him saying it.
But actually, it's not, because
the students, of
course, have none of
those thoughts.
And you really do need
to say all that.
Why?
OK.
We'll continue after our
10-minute break.
And then we'll induce our
lessons for lecture planning
and performance, and I'll give
you a structure that you can
use when you plan and perform
your own lectures.
OK?
There's several more
points to come out.
So we'll take some more points
about Lewin's lecture at--
It's 10:05 by that clock.
--10:15 by that clock.
And if you didn't get a comment
sheet, just grab one
on your way in or
on your way out.
And I'll be here if
people have any
questions during the break.
So a few other points.
Let me give you one point from
Lewin that I noticed and take
some more points from you too.
One I thought was very
interesting, and which is not
normally done in most physics
lectures on springs.
The way it's normally done in
the physics class, you would
do simple harmonic motion,
you'd study a whole bunch
about the spring, and then maybe
a few lectures later,
you might get to the pendulum.
But Lewin actually did both in
the same lecture, which I
thought was very interesting and
a really excellent choice.
It had some negative effects,
which is that there's less
time to talk about
things like this.
And maybe it feels like there's
more pressure to not
wait five seconds.
So it has maybe subtle pressures
in the wrong
direction, which maybe could
be mitigated by planning.
But it had a really great
advantage, which is that it's
this figure.
So if there's some idea you want
to teach, and the idea
you wanted to teach is simple
harmonic motion.
He called it Simple Harmonic
Oscillation, SHM is the
standard jargon in most
of the physics books.
If you want to teach that idea,
just showing it in one
example is not good enough for
the students, because they
can't separate the example
from the idea.
It's just one big morass,
and they can't draw
this dividing line.
So you have to give them
another example.
But if you give them a second
spring example, then it's
still too hard.
Suppose you do this and yet
another spring example.
Well, the problem is it still
the overlap here is too big.
So you need an example that
illustrates the core idea but
is quite different.
And the pendulum falls into
that pretty well.
It's different, in that--
and the order was correct too--
he first did the spring,
because the spring really is
pure simple harmonic motion.
The pendulum isn't,
but you have to
approximate to get it there.
So it shows how you get to
simple harmonic motion,
because you've seen it now.
And so the piece you're getting
to is the common thing
between the two examples.
And furthermore, it's different
enough that you can
see what's common
and what's not.
What's common is the structure
of the equation.
The structure of the
equation is--
So that's common.
And so you have a really
particular example here of
inducing the core idea, which
is if you just did simple
harmonic motion with the example
of a spring, students
may think simple harmonic
motion is this.
They think whenever you
have k/m you have
simple harmonic motion.
Whenever you don't have
k/m, you don't have
simple harmonic motion.
They may think that actually
it depends on
exactly what's here.
But because the second example
has something completely
different--
The second example, the
pendulum had g/l after
approximating it.
You get the same structure of
the equation, but a new
physical phenomena.
And it shares the common
feature of
simple harmonic motion.
So it's a really excellent way
of bringing out this idea and
borrowing most of the derivation
that he did before.
For example, he didn't have to
do resolve this equation with
these new parameters.
Once he'd solved this equation,
all he had to do is
substitute this into the
solution and get the new
solution instantly.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: He created emphasis
by using both gestures and
also modulating his
pace and pitch.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'll try to squeeze
it in here.
So he modulated his pace
and pitch, and his
gestures were very bold.
He talked about the spring.
He stretched the spring.
He actually almost
broke the spring.
Whenever he was describing
something, you could feel him
feeling it in his own body.
His gestures were bold, and
his pace was varied.
OK.
How does that help?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Conveys enthusiasm.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's exciting.
It conveys enthusiasm.
It punctuates.
There are several languages,
I think, which
have no vowels and--
Not no spaces.
Well, German approximately
has no spaces.
That's not quite true.
But that don't have vowels
or punctuation.
In the old days, for example,
there was no punctuation.
People just ran all the words
one after another.
You didn't put a period at
the end of sentences.
Without punctuation, you have to
work really hard to figure
out what are the units
of thought.
So by varying your pace and
pitch, you convey enthusiasm.
You convey enthusiasm
and structure.
So the pieces that are more
important get more importance,
because they're emphasized
accordingly.
That's actually fundamentally
important in writing.
I don't know if you know the
following recipe, but this is
the first-order term in
good clear writing.
Let's call it not fiction
writing but expository writing
is the right word.
The first-order term in
punctuating writing and giving
structured to your
writing is this.
A sentence starts with old
information that links to
something before.
It continues to--
This is how the sentence ends.
Whatever you put at the end of
the sentence, readers expect
that to be the thing that
you want to emphasize.
That's the new information.
There's maybe a fair amount
of new information in the
sentence, but this is the new
interesting information.
This is what readers assume
has emphasis.
And in the beginning of a
sentence, they look for things
that connect to what has
already happened.
It could connect to the last
emphasized thing in the last
sentence, the subject of the
last sentence, the thing that
was the topic, or the topic
of the paragraph.
It somehow links to stuff
before, and then you're going
to say something new about it.
So if you don't use that order,
it gets very confusing
for readers, because they expect
this to be emphasized,
but you're mentally emphasizing
something else,
and then they have to redo their
expectations each time.
So punctuation, the period
actually is a way of saying,
here came the most important
information.
And if you follow that
structure, you'll tap into
much better how your
readers understand.
If you want to know more about
that, I'll put some references
on the website.
This was partly developed by
Joseph Williams, a linguistic
at the University of Chicago
and George Gopen, who's an
English professor and law
professor at Duke.
And he's written a really
interesting article called,
him and Judith Swan--
it's called "The
Science of Science Writing"--
where he gives a whole bunch of
examples of restructuring
prose along these lines and how
much clearer it becomes.
And he's written two books,
actually, one on teaching this
approach to writing and one
on doing it yourself.
It's a textbook for
such a class.
One's called The Sense
of Structure.
I forget whether that's the
teaching book or the textbook.
But I'll put both titles on
the website So I highly
recommend that.
And what you'll see from this
is the huge importance of
punctuation.
And here, it's the same thing.
By varying the pitch, by giving
periods, semicolons,
and commas in the lecture, even
though you can't say, OK,
here's the period.
You don't say that, but you do
it by varying your pitch and
your volume and your tone.
You give structure.
And fundamentally important,
you also convey enthusiasm.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On the other hand,
I think in that lecture he
offered [INAUDIBLE]
[LOUDLY]
he always speaks like this,
[NORMAL VOLUME]
which intimidated
students a bit.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
He maybe does it too much.
In fact, he doesn't
vary enough.
It's sort of like the
radio in Spinal Tap.
It goes to 11, and
it starts at 10.
Because it's always loud.
The amplifier's always loud.
Yeah, I think he could
actually have
more dynamic range.
So let's see.
More--
In his defense--
Oh, yes.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Finish your thought.
PROFESSOR: OK.
In his defense, you could say,
well, when do you want to be
really quiet?
Well, that's when you're doing
something that's less important.
And he's actually such a good
lecturer that he planned the
lecture, I would say,
quite well.
He took out all the stuff that
normally you would find in a
lecture on this that's
kind of dull.
For example, one thing that
people do that's really kind
of dull is they may derive the
sinusoid as a solution.
And how did he derive
the sinusoid?
Spray paint.
They did an experiment.
He made it visible.
He had a spring oscillating up
and down with spray paint, so
it was spraying on a
big piece of paper.
And then he pulled the piece
of paper that way.
So as the spring oscillated up
and down and sprayed on the
sheet of paper, it made a track,
which you could see
developing.
And then he just showed
the class.
He said, what does
this look like?
And they said, oh, it looks
like a sinusoid.
There you go.
Now you skipped a whole bunch of
painful math, otherwise, to
make the guess.
And so either you guess it, or
you do a bunch of derivation.
He avoided both of those
problems by actually just
having the students see
for themselves.
In fact, he used the word see.
I want to make you
see what it is.
So he got that.
He's taken out a lot of stuff
where you would normally just
try to pretend you
weren't doing and
speak really quietly.
So that's maybe one explanation
for why his
dynamic range wasn't as
big as it should be.
But yeah, I think, generally,
the point is right that he's
so forceful and loud that it
would be better if he just had
a twice as much range.
AUDIENCE: Just an
extra comment.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And this maybe be
necessary in the old days when
you don't have microphones
in lectures.
But when you have microphones,
you can speak colloquially but
still very clear to
the students.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
You have amplification.
Yeah.
And he did have a microphone,
because he was being taped.
But you're right.
The habits of thought in
presentation come from when we
didn't have microphones.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The one thing I would
change is at the very
beginning he was talking
about the test results.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And he said the test
results were better, on
average, than in
previous years.
And he said, oh, you're either
a smart class or the
test was too easy.
Just generally, calling the
students smart seems pretty
alienating for the students
who did poorly.
And then even the kids who did
well, there's pretty good
evidence that saying "you're
smart" rather than "you're
working hard", the latter's
much more effective.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's a really good point.
Yeah, the test results
discussion at the beginning.
I always knew this lecture was a
classic one, and this is the
first time I watched it straight
through, rather than
just watching the sort of
demonstration parts and the
famous parts.
And so it started off with this
discussion about test
results where he says all kinds
of interesting things.
"You did very well on your first
exam." That's word one
in the lecture.
"I was hoping for an average
of about 75." So hoping,
that's not a word I
would have used.
I would hope for an
average of 100.
That's my hope.
Maybe not what I expect,
but my hope is 100.
So by saying hope, he's saying,
actually, it would be
good if people got a lot of
stuff wrong, like I'm hoping
that people get 25% wrong.
That could be interpreted
as hoping that the
students don't do great.
But then, on the other hand,
the class average was 89.
OK.
So that's good news.
Now, as you say, he says,
"either you are very smart,
this is an exceptional class, or
the exam was too easy." And
he eventually concludes, no,
the exam was taken by the
instructor, so you guys
are smart class.
But even that he takes away by
saying, "but time will tell
whether you are indeed
exceptionally smart or whether
the exam was too easy."
So even the good news
is tempered and
taken partly back.
And then even the good news
itself, as you point out
correctly, is not necessarily
good for helping
the students learn.
So there's very interesting
studies--
I wish I could remember
the name.
She's a psychology professor
at Stanford, and she's done
studies with kids.
What you do is you have the kids
do a problem, and then
you tell them either that they
worked hard at it or that they
were very smart.
That's why they solved it.
You tell Group A that,
oh, yeah, you worked
really hard at it.
That's why you solved it.
Group B, you say, oh,
yeah, you solved it.
You must be really smart.
And then you see what kind of
problems they try later.
Let's do Group B first, who are
told you did it because
you were smart.
Later--
this is making an extreme of
it, but this is the trend--
they don't want to solve
hard problems.
Because the only thing you can
get out of solving a hard
problem is you don't solve it,
which then proves that you're
actually not as smart
as people though.
So they want to solve
easy problems.
The group that was told, oh,
yeah, you did that because you
worked really hard, they enjoy
solving the problems.
And they want to solve hard
problems that they can't
necessarily solve, because
they can work on them.
And some of them even say things
like, oh, I love it
when a problem's hard, which
is a completely different
attitude than the attitude of
the people who are like, oh, I
don't want to try anything.
Because I might fail, and
then the truth about
me will come out.
By making comments about
people's intrinsic
characteristics--
I made distinction earlier
between intrinsic motivation
and extrinsic motivation and
how you really want to use
intrinsic motivation.
But there's the flip one, which
is you don't want to
make intrinsic comments about
people, because that's very
hard to change and very fixed.
And that's what people are
doing way too much of.
So whenever people can't solve
things, it's because you
didn't work hard enough, the
conditions weren't right, you
can call it making excuses,
but it isn't.
It's an optimistic way of
looking at the world.
And it's that optimism that
people learn when they have
control over the things that
lead to problem-solving
successfully or not.
Yeah, I thought the opening was
actually very bad in terms
of that and actually set
a kind of competitive,
hierarchical tone, which I would
have definitely avoided.
Other comments?
Other things you noticed?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: He kind of oozed with
passion about the subject.
Usually, [INAUDIBLE]
5,000, he still seemed amazed
that they worked.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right.
Let me erase this guy.
He's shedding passion.
He's oozing passion.
I'm sure he's done the demo
many, many times for every
semester, no doubt.
Yet he was still so excited.
For example, the ending,
what did he say?
They did 10 oscillations
with Walter Lewin as
the pendulum bob.
And then they counted
up to 10.
So then he got to 10t with
Walter Lewin, 45.6, plus or
minus 0.1 seconds.
And the prediction was 45.7,
plus or minus 0.1, so it was
right on the nose.
He said, "Physics works,
I'm telling you.
See you Monday." So he
ends with enthusiasm.
He is enthusiasm throughout,
all the way through.
Yeah, it is contagious.
People did applaud, and I'm sure
it wasn't just because it
was being taped.
They really were very pleased
and amazed at the close
agreement, even when he changed
the pendulum bob from
just the regular pendulum bob
of a few kilograms to Walter
Lewin of 70 kilograms or--
he's probably more--
probably 80 kilograms.
And throughout as well, doing
the demonstrations, he was
also very enthusiastic.
And even sometimes he got lucky,
and he even said so.
But he said, fantastic agreement
between theory and
experiment.
Yeah, so the enthusiasm,
it transfers.
And in fact, our system, our
brain is actually much better
at picking up this kind of stuff
than it is at picking up
the Navier-Stokes equation
and things like that.
Let's call it an emotional
highway.
It goes in the emotional
So I mentioned the experiment
that you can do to test this.
The experiment you do is you
just go somewhere and you just
smile at people.
And now 30%, 40%, 50% of the
class is smiling back already.
You can't help it.
Even though you know
and I'm telling you
I'm just doing this--
There's nothing actually funny
that just happened right now.
I'm just smiling, just because
I'm a nice guy and I'm
smiling, and I just wanted you
to see if the experiment
works-- you can't help it.
So that tells you how powerful
that emotional highway is.
It's not just for smiling.
It's the oozing passion.
Neurobiologically, that
mechanism is starting to be
understood.
I'll write the mechanism down.
We have what are called
mirror neurons.
What mirror neurons do is they
recreate the state of mind of
other people in us.
So that's why they're called
mirror neurons.
And they're innate.
It seems that monkeys
have them.
We have them.
There's nothing you
can do about them.
And they are actually probably
the mechanism by which we
become social creatures
and which
makes us social creatures.
So if people around us are
unhappy, we feel unhappy.
If people around us are
happy, we feel happy.
And these mirror neurons, their
firing tendencies are
partly set in young childhood.
So if the people around you are
happy in childhood, you'll
have a much easier time just
automatically being happy later.
And if the people around you
in childhood are really
unhappy and your childhood's
unhappy, you have to work much
harder later to overcome that.
So that's the importance
of childhood and child
upbringing.
But now these are there, and
your students all have them,
being people.
So how you act and how you
perform is going to affect
them much more strongly than
any equation you say.
It's fundamentally
important, again.
OK.
Any other points?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was thinking about the
use of the spray--
PROFESSOR: The spray paint can?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And it wasn't until now
that I actually
understood why he did that.
Because when I saw it, I was
sort of thinking, why is he
doing that?
Or if he pulled the
lever faster, it's
going to look the same.
I didn't get it at all.
And now I see it was to guess
the solution [INAUDIBLE].
And then I'm thinking, when
I was taught the harmonic
oscillator for the first time,
that's an opportunity the
professor used to actually teach
how to solve, OK, this
is the differential equation,
and this is the
solution for it.
And now you know for the
rest of your life.
Because solving a differential
equation by [INAUDIBLE],
you're not always going to have
an experiment to solve--
PROFESSOR: To show it.
AUDIENCE: Right.
It's kind of cool.
But I'm not quite sure
what's the purpose.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what's the purpose?
It could go here or here,
the spray paint example.
The normal way it's done is that
you either just guess it
outright, you say, well, we've
seen that equation before--
we being the royal we-- the
instructor's seen the equation
before and says, use
the sinusoid.
The students have never seen
it before and just have to
take it on faith.
Then you put in the sinusoid,
and then you show that it
solves the equation.
The other way you do it is you
separate the equation.
There's many techniques for
solving that equation.
One is you write it in terms
of operators and factor the
operators, but the freshman
aren't really ready for that.
So you can't really do that.
You're basically reduced to
guessing, at least in the
American curriculum.
Now what he's done is he's done
an improvement on that.
Instead of saying just by bold
assertion, just outright
authority saying, please guess
this, he's saying, look, this
is what it did.
What do you think it is?
And then the students say,
oh, it's a sinusoid.
He says, OK, good.
That justifies the guess,
basically, that I was going to
make anyway.
So it improves on the standard
method of guessing and just
plugging in.
But you're right.
Not always can you do that.
So maybe the thing I would have
done is, if I were him, I
would have said, ah, this is
going to avoid us just either
guessing the solution or doing a
whole big, long calculation.
And he does say that elsewhere
when he talks about the zoo,
when he wrote down the
differential equations for the
x motion and the y motion.
He said, oh, that has a coupled
nonlinear equation.
It's hopeless.
It looks like a zoo,
and it is a zoo.
So then he approximated it.
He was quite good at saying,
look, there's some things you
just don't want to do.
And this would have
been, I think,
another spot to do that.
He could have explained why
he was going to do the
experiment.
OK.
Just one other point, I think,
that wasn't mentioned so far.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, he never erases
what he's using.
We'll talk about that more the
next time when we talk about
using chalk and slides.
If you notice, he never erased
anything he needed.
Now you could just
call that chance.
So an example of when
he had stuff that
he was using before.
He had the differential
equation, and then that was
way up on some board.
And then later, after doing the
experiment with the spray
paint, he came to x equals--
So now he had to calculate x and
x dot, the derivative, and
x double dot and
then put it in.
Well, as he was doing that,
fortunately this equation was
still there the whole time.
It was just high up.
So he never erased anything
he needed later.
And I was watching
pretty carefully
through the whole lecture.
I think there was no time
when that had happened.
And you could call
that chance.
Maybe if it happened once
it would just be chance.
But it's actually preparation.
So that's part of lecture
preparation.
What am I going to need?
And how do I make sure that
it's still visible?
Or you can write it again.
That's also fine.
But how do I make it so that
students don't have to
remember it, flip back
in their notes?
Because to them, this
is a new equation.
It's not just the equivalent
of one pawn, one chunk.
It's six or seven chunks.
So you don't want to fill up
their short-term memory trying
to remember that.
You want it visible somewhere.
And that was also planning.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: He calls
tension a force.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, he did
call tension a force.
I was most upset about that.
That is the standard way it's
done, and all the physics
courses I took as
an undergraduate
did the same thing.
And I'm sure that's how I
got confused about it.
I'm sure most people
are confused about
it because of that.
And until they do a few thought
experiments or have to
teach it and really sort through
it, they won't figure
out that it's actually
not a force.
Now I'm sure Walter Lewin
doesn't internally think of it
as a force.
He knows it behaves
differently.
But it's so easy to use this
shorthand, and then the
students, they don't have any
other structure for it.
They'll just think it does
act like a force.
It add vectors, but
it doesn't.
Yeah.
So that was, I thought,
a dubious point.
But it's standard,
unfortunately.
It's a good lesson that just
because something's standard
doesn't mean it's a
good thing to do.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: He used the big
chalk and colors.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, big yeah.
Right.
Actually, if you need to order
this chalk, it's called
railroad crayon.
You want to be careful to get
railroad crayon, because there
is actually big chalk you can
buy from, I don't know,
variety stores.
And that's for, for example,
writing messages on sidewalks.
And the problem with that is
that has wax in it so that it
stays against the rain.
But that's not so good
for the blackboard.
It's much harder to get off.
Railroad crayon is designed
to be removed easily.
If you order railroad crayon,
unfortunately it seems to come
in boxes of 144.
Maybe you can get a box of 72.
So share it around.
If you find a source with
smaller amounts, let me know.
But the ones we found were 144,
a gross, one dozen dozen.
But yeah, he used railroad
crayon, so it was very easy to
see what he was doing.
And he used colors.
For example, forces
were always read.
And he used a consistent naming
convention for that, so
he wasn't throwing noise
onto the system.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This was mentioned
before, but I think one
important thing he did
is that he created
suspense by taking a risk.
Because he repeated the full
experiment in class.
Because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: He created suspense
by taking a risk.
So there was actually tension,
not this kind of tension, but
the good kind attention where
people were involved in
interested.
Because he redid the experiment,
and it could have
come out not quite right.
And amazingly, it did
come out right.
And when it does, then the point
he's trying to make it
even more strongly reinforced
about physics works.
And that was his goal.
That was one of his overall
goals for the implicit.
I don't know if he ever stated
it, but one of his implicit
goals, you can see, is
to convince people
that physics works.
It's a way of understanding
the world.
And if you really believe that,
well, you should be
willing to put your money
where your mouth
is and do it yourself.
There's an another famous
experiment--
I don't know if it's in
Lewin's lectures--
where you want to show that
energy is conserved.
And the way you measure energy
conservation is how far a
pendulum swings.
So now the way you do the
experiment, you have some
giant pendulum with a bowling
ball or a cannon ball at the
end hanging from the top of
the physics lecture hall,
which is about this high.
And you release it from
your nose, and
you just stand there.
So if energy's really conserved,
it's going to come
just to where you released it
and no farther, which is good
because your nose
is right there.
A little farther would hurt.
The problem--
this still doesn't show physics
doesn't work, but it
looks like it--
is that it's so tempting to give
it a little push when you
release it.
And it's just hard not to do,
because whenever you let go of
things, you push a ball,
you throw something
in the laundry basket.
So now you give it
a little bit of
push, and physics works.
So it comes back with exactly
the same push, which wouldn't
be a problem if it was a
wiffleball or a tennis ball.
But because it's a giant cannon
ball and at the other
end of it's your nose,
it gives you a nice
crunch right there.
I would only do that expect if
I'd practiced it and make sure
I didn't push it.
But even if you do push it, it
too shows physics works.
But yeah, he created suspense.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how can people do
this in other disciplines?
In physics, you have weights
and swinging
pendulums and blocks.
PROFESSOR: How can you do
it in other fields?
Yeah, it's a good question.
If you remember, the
wood blocks--
this is physics, mechanical
engineering--
there was also suspense.
Because when I tap this one,
and then everyone was dead
silent before we tapped
this one--
just for review--
because everyone
wanted to know.
So suspense was created.
And it's just like any sort of
magic trick or performance.
You have to prepare it.
So it doesn't have to be that
you bring something in.
It helps.
But, let's see, what else
could you do it in?
Chemistry.
In chemistry--
it helps to bring stuff
in, no question-- you
could bring in chemicals.
What do you think is going to
happen when I mix these two?
Well, what do we know
about this?
What do we know about this?
What's going to happen when I
drop a ball through this?
Is this viscous?
Is it not?
What clues did you have?
OK.
Let's see if now that's
consistent with
how the thing behaves.
So it doesn't have to
be pure physics.
Though it does help to bring
things in, and so you do want
to make everything you have as
visceral and as visualizable
as possible.
So that is a general
transferable principal.
Let me write down four general
principles that you can use in
all lecture performance,
which is basically
everything you said here.
The first one I'm going to write
down is very neglected,
but you've just mentioned
it, which is the
suspense and the timing.
If you want evidence that timing
really matters, just go
watch Romeo and Juliet again,
or read Romeo and Juliet.
Just because they were slightly
off in their timing,
they all committed suicide,
basically.
That's probably the very, very,
very, very CliffsNotes
plot summary.
And another part about timing,
if you want more evidence that
timing really matters, try
telling a joke and tell the
punchline first.
See how well that does.
And even a small example of
that, for stories too.
Stories, you want to tell the
important part later, and you
want to give the introduction
first.
Again, remember the sentence
structure here, which is that
the thing with emphasis comes
right at the end.
If the thing you want to
emphasize happened at the
beginning, then your
timing is off, and
things will fall flat.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But that's exactly contradictory
to the way some
people want their information
laid out, which is tell me the
most important thing, and then
back up with all the details.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So that's a good comment, which
is that it's opposite of
how people say they
want things.
They want the most important
stuff first
and then the details.
The way I square that circle is
I don't want to give away
punchlines.
Oh, those are gone.
So suppose I'm starting a new
unit, and we're going to do a
unit on extreme cases.
I don't want to give away the
punchline, which is, oh, this
problem is hard until you
use extreme cases.
So I say, forget the
organization of the course
that I told you about before,
and we're just going to do an
example and discuss it.
Then we're going to look at what
makes it really easy, and
then the punchline
is extreme cases.
OK.
Now that we know the punchline,
because we've done
the example, now I'm very happy
to say extreme cases.
Let's use extreme cases here.
And this whole unit is going
to be about extreme cases.
So now people still have the
structure, but the very
beginning of it, they're
a little confused.
And I like the confusion.
So that's part of this.
In a play or in a movie, or you
go to a movie, you're not
even sure who are the
main characters and
what are they up to.
And then it comes into focus
soon but not right away.
And part of that is
to draw you in.
Yeah.
I wouldn't begin a lecture by
telling people everything that
they need to know, because
that's spoiling the timing.
The beginning of the lecture is
this kind of sacred moment
when you want to draw everybody
into the lecture.
And the beginning of a course
is doubly that much.
You want to draw people in, not
tell them, oh, yeah, here
are the rules on homework
collaboration and blah, blah,
blah, blah.
You want to emphasize the
important things first, and
you want to use this to pull
people in so that you can come
to a punchline.
The punchline doesn't have to
be way at the end of the
lecture or the end
of the course.
It can be soon, and you can have
a lot of soon punchlines.
But for each one, you
need to build to it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
When I did my referencing thing,
the first slide had a
list of goals that I wanted to
make, because I thought that
that was what we should be
talking about in [INAUDIBLE]
teaching.
And then you asked, would you
have included those when you
started the real lecture?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And I said,
I wouldn't.
I would just plunge right into
the material, because I was
thinking along the line of
what you're saying now.
And then you said, no, I think
it's actually good for the
students to see it outlined what
they're going to learn.
And so that's actually
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's right.
I think what I would do is I
would show them that goals--
Goals are OK, as long as you
don't begin the lecture by
saying, here are my goals,
because that's that secret
time you're taking away from.
I would put the goals, say, on
a side board, so they can see
them all the time, or write the,
just after you've done
your punchline.
Then put them all up.
AUDIENCE: So it's the second
or third slide.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
The very first slide is
something interesting that
doesn't necessarily seem like
it's related to the class.
And that's already
a punchline.
Oh, wow, this?
We can understand this from
the stuff in class?
I want to know.
That's a drawing in.
And then you get to the
punchline, which
is, yes, you can.
And the goals are to see this
all over and see these three
principles that we just used
and really understand them.
OK Another one be bold,
so bold gestures.
Bold gestures, voice,
you'll see that all
throughout Walter Lewin.
Another one, we've actually
done, I would say, a lot more
with it than you saw in the
lecture, which is--
And the third one is you want
to involve the audience by
asking them questions, making
your whole lecture
interactive.
So we've discussed, actually,
many ways where the Lewin
lecture could be improved
in that direction.
And perhaps underlying
everything, none of this
really works unless there's
principal four, which is that
you have to care.
You have to really, really love
what you're doing and
transmit that to the students.
And then, all of these
things become so much
easier when you care.
So those are the fundamental
principles of lecture
performing and, basically,
planning
around things like that.
And if I just had written those
down in the beginning,
it wouldn't have made sense.
But now you've seen many, many,
many examples, and we've
had many discussions about it
that I wish you success in
applying good timing, good
bold gestures, strong
gestures, and involving the
audience, not just emotionally
or cognitively but both, so that
you provide long-lasting
learning and interest in the
subject that you love.
OK.
If you could fill out the sheets
for just one minute.
And then we will have
office hours.
Actually, what we'll do is we'll
meet right outside the
door, and then we'll just
go sit in the cafe area.
And anyone who wants to get a
bagel can also get a bagel, if
you're interested.
Answers from Lecture
8 to questions
generated in Lecture 7.
PROFESSOR: So first question
was, a while ago I mentioned
there was research saying that
if you pay people for things
they like doing then they
start enjoying it less.
Can I give you a reference
for that?
The reference for that is I
actually put on the readings
for next week, which is the
political barriers to
educational change session,
one of the five readings--
they're all basically short--
is by Alfie Kohn, and it's
about competition.
And that's one of the areas
he researches a lot.
I gave you one of the short
articles by him to read.
But his whole website as lots
of different articles and
references.
He has a whole book
on the whole
subject called No Contest.
I think the subtitle is The
Case Against Competition.
So he goes through, I don't
know, 100 or 200 studies about
the effects of rewards
on people's
performance and interests.
It's a totally fascinating
book.
And I think it just came
out, or recently it
has the second edition.
But both editions are completely
fine, so whichever
one you can find, use that.
And on his website, you'll find
many articles on that
theme, and I've given you one
to read for next week.
OK.
What is the Berkeley
Physics Course?
The Berkeley Physics Course--
This is interesting, because in
the '60s there was a whole
bunch of change.
It was change in political
systems and protests and legal
systems, the Civil Rights Act.
And there was also change
in education.
And that's probably not
coincidence, that both changes
were coupled or happened
together.
There was the rise of the
Free School Movement.
There was also, in the
university level, lots of
different new curricula
started.
The Feynman Lectures on physics
are a famous one that
happened way over on
the other side of
the country and Caltech.
And the Berkeley Physics Course
happened also on the
other side of the country.
There are several
volumes in it.
Probably the best known
is Ed Purcell's
Electricity and Magnetism.
That's one of the classics of
the Berkeley Physics Course.
There's a less well-known
volume, which is, I think,
even better, which is
by Frank Crawford,
and it's called Waves.
The edition I have came in the
back with a whole bunch of
polarizers and toys you could
use to actually do home
experiments.
And at the end of every chapter,
there are home
experiments.
I think they're called "Kitchen
Sink Experiments, and
there were toys in the back in
the little pocket that you
could use for it.
So if you find a used copy,
those toys might not be there,
but the book is still
wonderful.
So those were two pieces of the
Berkeley Physics Course,
and they were about
six volumes.
And MIT had a whole set
of books as well, I
think by Tony French.
So it was a whole time of
ferment, and lots of changes
happened, many of them good.
OK.
How can you apply these lecture
techniques that we
talked about last time
to laboratory
or practical courses?
This is actually an important
topic, because many
of us will do that?
What's the right balance between
teaching and lecturing
and allowing students to solve
the lab problems on their own,
in other words, giving them
enough rope to hang
themselves?
Yeah.
You do want to do that.
You want to give people enough
rope, but you also want to
guide them, because you do
know more than them.
So I don't look at laboratory
teaching, practical teaching
as that different than
lecture teaching.
In some ways, it's easier,
because one of the goals in
lecture teaching is to show
people that all the theory
you're talking about actually
has any relevance at all.
And you have to try to work hard
to bring stuff into the
classroom and really show, yeah,
look this really means
something, the way Walter Lewin
stood on the pendulum or
sat on the pendulum himself and
was the pendulum to really
show, yes, this applies here.
In a laboratory practical class,
if the practicals are
at all interesting, that's
automatically done for you.
The last practical class I
taught was the electronics
practical for physics majors.
At the end, they built an AM
radio, a crystal radio.
So that actually had a nice
finale, and experiments before
that built up to it.
The relevance was already done
for me, but the problems the
students had were the same
as in regular lecture.
They didn't understand
the concepts.
For example, what does
a capacitor do?
What does an inductor do?
How do they work together?
What is resonance?
So what I did for them is
I gave them short little
mini-lectures, two minutes three
minutes on a conceptual
question, and then sent
them off working.
Some of the other problems they
had were, for example,
they were really scared
of oscilloscopes.
They just got to the
oscilloscope, and they
thought, what the hell do
I do with this thing?
So do I used an exercise that
was done to me when I took the
same class as an undergraduate,
which was in
your laboratory pair one person
turns around and the
other person randomizes the
oscilloscope settings.
They just turn all of dials to
some random setting, and then
the first person has to turn
back and try to get some
signal on the screen.
So they have to figure out, OK,
this voltage setting is
crazy and get it back
to a setting.
And once you do that, you're
no longer afraid of the
oscilloscope.
Again, you can do in
class problems that
people work on together.
You can give short little
conceptual questions.
So in a way, laboratory teaching
isn't that different,
provided that the laboratory
isn't just a cookbook in the
sense that, OK, do this, now
measure that, now measure
that, now measure that,
now measure that.
OK, write it all
in your report.
That's like lecturing just by
saying now copy this down, now
copy that down, now
copy that down.
So if you get away from that
in lecturing and that in
practical, then you get to the
similarities between the two,
and you can apply pretty much
every lesson from here.
OK.
Oh, yeah.
Many of you pointed this out.
The distillation of examples
into principles that we did.
So we looked at Walter Lewin's
lecture number 10, and then we
distilled from our discussion
various principles of
lecturing and performing.
And many of you said,
oh, yeah, that
should have gone longer.
You liked the principles, but
we should have done that for
longer, which I think
is a great sign.
I think it's good that you guys
are figuring out what
could be improved.
And I agree with you.
I just got so carried away
with all the interesting
things you were finding that I
didn't allocate enough time
for the principles.
So in my next life.
But also, the point is everyone
did appreciate having
principles, so that's something
to transfer for your
own teaching.
OK.
Let's see.
What kind of interactive
examples and demos can you do
for a math class?
I brought an example.
They're in here.
This was actually an example
I did last week in my
approximation class.
And I enjoyed it so
much I thought I'd
show it to you too.
The principal I was teaching
was the principle of easy
cases, also known as extreme
cases often.
But I like this name better.
And then I wanted to show that
this principle applies across
all kinds of areas.
You can use it in math.
You can use it in physics.
You can use it in engineering.
And what we were trying
to derive is
the volume of a pyramid.
So the original problem
was this.
You take a pyramid with a square
base, and then you lop
off some piece of the top.
So the pyramid is B by B on the
base and A by A square on
the top, and it has height h.
So what's the volume
of that thing?
Well, you can guess a lot
of it from easy cases.
I won't go through
all of that.
But at some point, you need to
work out in part of this guess
the easy cases, use the easy
case that A equals 0.
In other words, you just have a
regular square pyramid, like
one of the Egyptian
pyramids of Gaza.
Giza?
Giza, maybe.
So then what's the volume?
OK.
Well, volume's going to be
proportional to the height.
And then, it's got to have two
more lengths here, so it's got
to have B squared here.
There's no A left.
But then what goes here?
What's the constant?
Well, this is actually
where you can, yet
again, use easy cases.
So if you could find a special
pyramid that could be combined
into a shape whose volume you
know, then you could actually
figure out this constant.
Because you don't know the
volume of one pyramid, but if
you could replicate it and then
assemble them into a nice
shape, you're home free.
What nice shape could
make this into?
And what pyramid shape do you
need to be able to do that?
So take a minute and
think about that.
Anyone have an idea?
What shape would you
like to make?
AUDIENCE: Could you first make
a rectangular cube and then
cut it into six pieces?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you want to make a cube.
Let's talk about how you're
going to make this cube.
You'd like to make the cube.
Now what part of the pyramid
is going to become
the face of the cube?
Well, you have a square
base, right?
So it seems reasonable to expect
that each pyramid's
going to provide one
face the cube.
So you need six pyramids
to make this cube.
Well, what shape should the
pyramid have so that you can
fit them into a cube?
Hmm.
How about that shape?
So what's special about
that shape?
I'll put one here, and here's
another one of them.
Put that there.
And here's another one.
OK.
So here we go.
Here's a cube with six
of those pyramids.
So what's special about the
shape of the pyramid?
What do you have to set in it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The height is
half of the base line.
PROFESSOR: OK.
The height is half the base.
How do you know that?
AUDIENCE: Because the tips of
the pyramids are [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the tips touch like this.
And this width has to equal
either side of the square.
That means, let's say, if h
equals 1 and B equals 2, six
times the volume is equal
to the volume of the
cube, which is 8.
So the volume of one pyramid
is 8/6 or 4/3.
h times b squared is 4, so you
have to divide it by 3, and
you're home free.
So there's an example of a
demonstration in math class
that you can use.
Now the point of it is that it's
possible to imagine it in
your head, but it is actually
useful to see these things
built into a cube.
So even in math class you
can do demonstrations.
What's my blackboard
philosophy?
I write big and sometimes place
things fairly randomly.
Is there a specific
reason for this?
But I like what you
write down.
Yeah.
My blackboard philosophy
is not ideal,
because of exactly that.
I write large, which is good,
but I do place things kind of
randomly sometimes.
And that's not ideal, so
I try to improve that.
I don't necessarily have
a reason for that.
Don't actually copy that part
of my blackboard style.
But it's good that you're
observing that and trying to
criticize it.
OK.
Let's see.
How to practice blackboard
work.
We'll talk about that
more today.
But the basic simplest way that
I've found is at the end
of your session you just go to
the back of the room and look
at the blackboard and you just
see was it organized, did it
make sense, did I write a bunch
of stuff in between, and
just take a few notes
down on that.
And then you'll automatically
be getting feedback that you
can use to improve your
blackboard work.
Oh, yeah.
Several people pointed out
they watched a different
lecture than Walter Lewin's
Lecture 10, because I said,
oh, watch that one
or another one.
So next year, I actually am
going to ask everyone to watch
the same lecture, Lecture 10.
That's a good suggestion.
OK.
We talked about that.
Oh, yeah, if you're an excellent
lecturer and you are
aware of the common problems,
because you've taught the
course many times before, and
you try to address all the
confusing parts, can you get
away with not allowing
students to ask questions in
class and not asking students
questions yourself?
That's a very interesting
question.
Basically, can you move away
from the interactive model
I've been describing and
recommending once you've done
it enough and you know
where the students'
misconceptions are.
I thought about that, and
the answer is really no.
Because then you're reverting
back to telling.
Now you're telling them things
they really do need to know.
So instead of telling them a big
long song and dance about
the Atwood machine, which they
don't really need to know,
you're telling them about
their misconceptions
about F equals ma.
But the problem is just telling
them that F equals ma,
F equals mv, doesn't help
them realize that.
They really have to have some
kind of cognitive conflict and
struggle with it.
So questioning, either you
question them or them asking
questions of you and formulating
questions, is
really about the only way to get
them to struggle with it.
Even then, you still
have to do it.
And the experience you have from
teaching it many times
means you'll be doing questions
about useful,
important material.
That was quite an interesting
question.
OK.
What do I think of group
assignments, balancing the
advantages of collaboration
with the fact that each
individual may not encounter
all the topics?
I generally don't like
them that much.
I think if you design a course
and you think there's a
coherent set of material,
everyone really should try to
master that coherent set of
material and not palm off half
of it on one person in the
group and the other
person in the group.
The extreme of this kind is
the graduate seminar where
each graduate student gives
a talk on one topic.
And then they really learn that
one topic, but they don't
necessarily learn the other
topics very well.
So I don't like that
very much.
I think it's better to allow
people to collaborate, but
make sure everyone does
their own assignment.
And yeah, collaborate in groups,
by all means, but
please write up your
own work as well.
What's the use of experiments
in Walter Lewin's lecture?
Was it to show the predictive
power physics or its
experimental character?
It's not clear.
And in that case, wouldn't it
be better if the students
performed the experiments on
their own or in a lab class?
Aren't these demonstrations a
waste of time that could be
used to teach more theory?
And aren't shows more
appropriate for high school
classes than for
physics at MIT?
Well, I think, at the time, this
was 1999, there was no
laboratory with the introductory
physics course.
I need to get my history right,
but I'm pretty sure
that's right.
There was no other way the
students would ever see any
application.
But the other main point of it
is that it showed that the
physics is real.
Now I think it could be
improved, as you suggested, by
Lewin asking students
questions about the
experiments, trying to predict
what would happen beforehand,
for example.
But the idea of bringing in
objects is really a sound one.
I had a teacher at Caltech.
He taught the waves and the
nonlinear waves course.
He always used to bring in
a wave guide, which is,
basically, a piece of metal
in a tube-like shape.
and he said he always did that
because, otherwise, the
mathematicians would think it's
just a vessel function,
because that's how it is
in all the problems.
You see wave guide, you just
start solving Laplace's
equation with all these boundary
conditions, you get
Bessel function.
And wave guide is just trigger
for do Laplace's equation, get
Bessel function.
It has no physical meaning.
So he would always bring in
the wave guide so that you
knew that it was a real object
that you were analyzing.
And so in that way, Lewin, using
the pendulum, showing
that these things actually
exist, avoids the trap that
many students fall into, which
is that symbols just have no
meaning on their own.
They're just stuff that
goes on on the screen.
So I think is really important
that he does that.
OK.
Working hard versus smart.
How do you respond to people who
tell you that they worked
really hard but they
still did poorly?
I think, basically,
the reason is that
they didn't work smart.
So what do students think
working hard means?
They generally think it means
reading the book over and over
again or trying really hard
to do the problems but not
reflecting.
The equivalent in playing
chess is working hard at
chess, people think, oh, that
just means playing lots of
chess games.
But actually, that doesn't
improve your chess ability.
You have to analyze your chess
games, reflect on them.
And that's what we need to
teach students how to do.
So whenever they do say
that, I say, OK, well,
what are you doing?
Let's look at what you're doing
and see if there are
ways we can make it more
reflective and less just going
through the same stuff
over and over again.
And then, final comment--
there are some more questions,
but I'll leave
it there for now--
while watching the 801 Walter
Lewin lecture, I was surprised
how much I was able to find
wrong with it, even though
he's a great lecturer.
That goes to show how much we've
learned so far in this
class, which I thought was
a very nice comment.
I'm glad.
And I hope people did draw
that conclusion.
From all this stuff that you
found to improve that lecture
means you have actually learned
a lot, either in this
class or elsewhere, and you
could actually make really
excellent lecturers, really
powerful, constructive
lecturers yourself.